hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John huh we're gonna watch a video
today from our home and mr krepo
comments on her channel once you know
why - he's got one here Avengers and
game dunk earth style which I could see
how it lends itself yeah totally the
spare you fallen heroes people trying to
return home band together survival hope
you see one of our top reward tiers and
our page from pages whatever video you
request we must definitely do and put up
on YouTube the day comes from a Canadian
bustard Lance door you [ __ ] on the
floor because Avengers related it's
wrong where am i Captain Marvel sure
today they live we sleep
just like the paper with the yeah I got
the exact text
[Music]
he's like the Kenneth yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Christian Russia get the vengers endgame
and game is pong avenges hanging
universe he's good he's got good ribs
I mean generally speaking is almost
exactly what I imagined it to sort of be
like he's smart when he uses like he
pulls images from the infinity war movie
okay to set up that cos right here
they're doing one of these am i how are
you do this was just like the one little
Lou barely have any footage of this
movie right walked into that one
it's just so having to pull different
images and it like you have the
harrowing effect of the war invasion
going on that you're just stuck on this
battlefield in a way and in the last
like 30 seconds of this is like the
hopeful side like the despair but
hopeful element to it and of course you
know using this similar type of text to
the dunker trophy all the dialogue is
for the most part kind of incidental
it's mostly reactions and just yeah the
stakes of the physical environment in
the physical situation and you know
carrying over the ticking clock and then
the heartbeats yeah it really does even
though there's a lot more specific
characters to cut to whereas Dunkirk is
more of just a big old ensemble like it
really does lend itself in a weird way
especially to end games marketing these
are always sort of fun to break down
especially if you remember the trailers
like the one that he's referencing here
kids in the Duncker trailer you have the
set up of here's everything that's
happened now that the invasion has begun
not invasion but you know like the setup
of because I skew attempt yeah and
because in here they're saying like oh
Danis did what he said he was gonna do
so it's kind of throwing you into the
midst of the action both sides in here
yeah it's like both sides of dial are
kind of giving us the lay of the land at
the moment yeah here's the way things
are
thanos did exactly what he said he was
gonna do it's like you can't exactly
mirror it but there's things with
specific timing that they do like when
Kenneth Branagh and the dunker TRO says
there are 400,000 men on this Beach and
we cut through the shot of a oh yeah but
debrief on the beach and then in this
trailer would mr. crup Jessie says we're
in the gang then cut to the shop with
infinity war would Nick Fury's moment
into the explosion the chaos you know
some mirroring that element then after
saying from director Christopher Nolan
dancing firm the Russo brothers and the
doctor trailer is the person walking and
going into the ocean pretty much you
know hopeless giving up on life and then
using the shot in mr. Crouch's video of
Tony Stark
hopeless give it up on life almost
pretty much you know as he's given a
goodbye speech in that moment oh yeah
yeah well and he's got a similar vacant
stare to the boys on the beach watching
that yeah walk into the water so in that
way you know it's kind of got a dual in
one in yeah than at the actual kind of
around the minute mark is when both sort
of start to show you what the actual
enemy offensive looks like with both you
know the airships flying over you know
shooting at the beach and stuff like
that and at the boats and then also Nick
Fury getting out and the chaos in the
streets starting to disintegrate and
stuff like that so in very different
ways the enemy is present structurally
actually he's doing pretty kitchen and
the dunker sure they have the kilian
trillion zillion brazilian murphy he is
talking in a despairing way and then
Mark Rylance is talking with him more
violence is talking with him because
suing murder is talking about the
devastation factor of like I don't want
to go back I'm traumatized you know and
then Mark Rylance is saying what we have
to basically yeah we got a help and he
kind of gave Captain America mr. crash
just gave Captain America both of those
roles yeah yeah talking about the trauma
but then also talking about like this
has to work cuz I don't know what I'm
gonna do if it doesn't we have to do
this yeah as you know yeah one
structurally to it this is the point
where you know both of these kind of
shift into okay what's everybody outside
the main kind of hot point of the
situation doing and what's the
counter-offensive look like or or what
is the rest
you look like and stuff like that so if
the matically you know similar at least
and then you know the rest of it just
heroes struggling and looking hopeless
cutting do a lot of different character
different characters out hard trying
their best maybe even feeling a little
hopeful mostly feeling yeah and then you
know I think it's Kent brought up has
that line I almost see it from here yeah
and then Robert Downey jr. they use the
you know say Chong part of the
beginnings the end or someone that
sometimes the end is the most important
place for a new beginning yeah is that
what part of the journey use the end
remember everything except for yeah it's
the end guys hard to go have a lot of
memory say yeah that was really cool man
you freaking cut this bad boy together
really well another great job on the
editing me go go to breaking these down
man someday I swear you're gonna be
cutting just the regular trailer yeah
and we do a good job at trying to
decipher what you were going for
I give ourselves credit for that listen
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation please click that notification
bell and last but not least patron of
the day shout out for Lance dole and in
a recent exchange of messages with Lance
door he said specifically because I was
complimenting him I'm being such a good
person said we always joke that in order
to be a fireman he's a fireman first
responder and live a normal life you
gotta be dead inside maybe I am but I
love being a father and a family man and
he goes on to elaborate when I called
him out on it he was saying well den
incise just an over exaggerated term we
use that work it's more just most of my
co-workers and myself are just used to
that high intensity of the calls like I
can go to a car accident that I bought
some gruesome things and go back to the
hall and eat a cheeseburger and act as
if nothing happened lol and because he's
pledged to play this kindly but I'm here
to tell you publicly you're a sociopath
man sick and you re committed sturb dude
is wrong with you how can you go see a
dead body and then eat a cheese
burger eat a salad at least if I were
you I would eat the cheese burger first
then go see the dead body that's how you
deal with necrophilia me that's we're
talking about right that's exactly what
we're talking about yeah oh no he can't
go back it's not I don't I don't I don't
do necrophilia I don't know why you'd
even imply that Lance I've never tried
necrophilia but I don't think I would
well if you get the cheeseburger like
Lance this is Jess oh yeah cheeseburger
is the garnish until the shoutouts not
about me and what I do on my private
time I'm sorry this is about Lance
and how you're a brave human being and
I'm glad you can endure the disgusting
things while enjoying a double
cheeseburger subscribe to the real
rejects subscribe to mr. treacherous
check us out on the Internet bye